N'est-ce-pas incroyable tout le contrôle
que les pirates peuvent acquérir par cette simple opération ?
Je vais vous montrer comment la plupart des logiciels malveillants
sont distribués aujourd'hui.
Je vais ouvrir un site internet
que j'ai créé.
Ce n'est pas un bon site. Les graphiques sont vraiment mauvais.
Il y a une section pour les commentaires ici
où on peut laisser son avis sur le site.
Beaucoup d'entre vous auront déjà utilisé quelque chose du même genre.
Malheureusement, lorsque ça a été développé,
le programmeur avait un peu bu
et réussi à oublier
toutes les règles de sécurité qu'il avait apprises.
Alors imaginons que notre pirate,
nommé Pirate de L'enfer, juste pour la blague,
insère quelque chose de pas très gentil.
C'est un script.
C'est un programme qui sera par la suite interprété sur la page internet.
Donc je vais publier ce message,
puis, sur l'ordinateur de la victime,
je vais ouvrir une page internet,
et aller sur ma page,
www.incrediblyhacked.com.
Remarquez qu'après quelques secondes,
on m'a redirigé vers une autre page.
L'adresse du site sur la barre URL
que vous voyez tout juste, microshaft.com,
le navigateur plante au moment il rencontre un de ces packs d'exploits,
et ouvre un faux antivirus.
C'est un virus qui ressemble à un logiciel antivirus,
qui va parcourir le système,
Regardez ce qui va apparaître.
Le logiciel crée des alertes inquiétantes.
Regardez, un serveur proxy de pornographie infantile.
Il faut vraiment effacer ça.
Ce qui est vraiment offensant dans l'histoire
c'est que non seulement les pirates peuvent avoir accès à vos données,
mais lorsque le scan est fini, ils vous disent
que pour effacer les faux virus,
il faut souscrire à ce produit.
Je préférais quand les virus étaient gratuits.
(Rires)
Certaines personnes payent maintenant les cybercriminels
pour mettre en place des virus,
ce que je trouve franchement bizarre.
Bref, accélérons la cadence.
Poursuivre 250 000 logiciels malveillants chaque jour
est un défi incroyable,
et ces chiffres ne font qu'augmenter
en proportion avec la ligne de stress que j'ai sur le front, vous remarquerez.
Donc je voudrais vous parler brièvement
d'un groupe de pirates que nous avons suivi pendant un an
et que nous avons réussi à trouver --
un événement rare dans notre profession.
C'était une collaboration entre différentes industries
des employés de Facebook, des chercheurs indépendants,
des gars de Sophos.
Voici quelques documents
que nos cybercriminels avaient mis en ligne
sur un service de stockage en ligne type Dropbox ou SkyDrive,
que certains d'entre vous utilisent peut-être.
En haut, vous verrez une section de code source.
C'est ce qui envoie un message aux cybercriminels
chaque jour pour leur dire combien d'argent
ils ont gagné ce jour-là,
c'est comme une fiche de paye pour cybercriminels si vous voulez.
Si vous regardez un peu plus près, vous remarquerez
une série de numéros de téléphone russes.
C'est bien sûr ce qui nous intéresse,
car ça nous donne les moyens de retrouver les cybercriminels.
En dessous, encadré en rouge,
dans la deuxième partie du code,
apparaît : « leded:leded »
C'est un nom d'utilisateur,
un peu comme ceux qu'on trouve sur Twitter.
Poussons l'expérience un peu plus loin.
Il y a d'autres éléments intéressants
que les cybercriminels ont téléchargés.
Beaucoup d'entre vous utilisent leurs smartphones
pour prendre des photos et les publier depuis cette conférence.
Nombre de smartphones ont une caractéristique intéressante :
quand vous prenez une photo,
les données GPS de l'endroit où la photo a été prise sont incorporées.
En fait, j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
sur des sites de rencontres récemment,
pour mes recherches bien sûr,
et j'ai remarqué qu'environ 60%
des photos de profil sur ces sites
indiquent les coordonnées GPS du lieu où la photo a été prise,
ce qui est plutôt effrayant
car personne ne voudrait donner l'adresse de son domicile
à tout un tas d'inconnus,
mais on communique volontiers les coordonnées GPS
à environ 15 mètres près.
Nos cybercriminels ont fait la même chose.
Voici une photo qui nous mène à Saint-Pétersbourg.
Nous déployons donc notre outil de piratage incroyablement développé.
On utilise Google.
Avec les adresses e-mail, le numéro de téléphone
et les données GPS, d'un côté, vous verrez une publicité
pour une BMW qu'un de nos cybercriminels souhaite vendre,
et de l'autre, une annonce pour vendre des chatons sphinx.
Une de ces annonces correspondait plus à l'image que je me faisais d'un pirate.
Après quelques recherches, voici notre cybercriminel.
Imaginez, ce sont des pirates, des durs
qui ne partagent que très peu d'information.
Alors imaginez ce que vous pourriez trouver
à propos de chacun d'entre vous ici présents.
En fouillant un peu plus son profil,
on trouve une photo de leurs bureaux.
Ils travaillaient au troisième étage.
Vous pouvez aussi voir des photos
de son associé
ce qui nous montre son intérêt pour une catégorie de photos bien précise.
Notre pirate s'avère être un membre de la Fédération des Webmasters Adultes de Russie.
C'est à ce moment là que notre enquête commence à ralentir.
Les cybercriminels ont réussi à verrouiller leurs profils.
Ce qui nous mène à la grande leçon
sur les réseaux sociaux et les appareils mobiles qui s'adresse à nous tous.
Nos amis, nos familles et nos collègues
peuvent violer notre sécurité même si nous avons pris les bonnes mesures.
Voici MobSoft, une des sociétés
qui appartenaient à ce gang de cybercriminels.
Ce qui est intéressant à propos de MobSoft,
c'est que le copropriétaire de cette société
a publié une offre d'emploi,
qui contenait un des numéros de téléphone
trouvés dans le programme de tout à l'heure.
Cette femme s'appelle Maria,
c'est la femme d'un de nos cybercriminels.
C'est comme si elle avait changé les paramètres de ses réseaux sociaux
et avait coché toutes les options imaginables
pour que son profil soit vraiment très peu sécurisé.
À la fin de l'enquête,
vous pouvez lire le rapport de 27 pages en cliquant sur ce lien,
nous avions des photos des cybercriminels,
et même des photos de leur fête de Noël au bureau
et de leur excursion.
Oui, oui, les cybercriminels fêtent aussi Noël
en fin de compte.
Vous vous demandez sûrement ce qui a bien pu leur arriver.
J'y reviendrai dans une minute.
Je voudrais juste vous montrer une dernière chose,
une technique simple et fondamentale,
mais intéressante pour savoir quelles informations
chacun de nous dévoile,
c'est important car cela s'applique à nous tous, spectateurs de TED.
En général, c'est à ce moment-là que tout le monde commence à fouiller ses poches
pour essayer désespérément de mettre leur téléphone en mode avion.
Beaucoup d'entre vous sont familiers avec le concept
de scan des réseaux wifi.
Vous le faites à chaque fois que vous sortez votre iPhone ou votre Blackberry
et le connectez à un réseau type TEDAttendees.
Mais ce que vous ignorez peut-être
c'est que vous diffusez aussi la liste de réseaux
auxquels vous étiez connecté dans le passé,
même sans activement utiliser le wifi.
Donc j'ai fait un scan.
J'ai été relativement timide par rapport aux cybercriminels,
qui ne se soucient pas tant de la loi,
voilà mon téléphone portable.
D'accord ? Vous voyez donc la liste des réseaux wifi.
TEDAttendees, HyattLB. Vous avez deviné où je loge ?
Le réseau de mon domicile, PrettyFlyForAWifi,
je trouve que c'est un nom génial.
Sophos_Visitors, SANSEMEA, des sociétés avec lesquelles je travaille.
Loganwifi, à Boston. HiltonLondon.
CIASurveillanceVan.
On a choisi ce nom lors d'une conférence
car on a pensé que ça ferait peur à tout le monde,
ce qui est plutôt drôle.
C'est comme ça qu'on s'amuse, nous les Geeks.
Rendons ça plus intéressant.
Parlons un peu de vous.
23% d'entre vous sont allés à Starbucks
récemment et ont utilisé leur wifi.
Encore mieux.
46% d'entre vous peuvent être associés avec une entreprise,
réseau d'employés XYZ.
Ce n'est pas une science exacte, mais ça devient de plus en plus précis.
Je pourrais identifier les hôtels où ont logé 761 d'entre vous,
et trouver précisément où ils se trouvent sur cette planète.
234 d'entre vous, eh bien, je sais où vous habitez.
Le nom de votre réseau wifi est tellement unique
que j'ai pu mettre le doigt dessus
en utilisant les données disponibles librement sur internet
sans astuces ou ruses de pirate.
Il faut aussi que je précise
que certains d'entre vous utilisent leur nom,
« iPhone de James Lyne » par exemple.
Et 2% d'entre vous ont des tendances obscènes.
À méditer :
En adoptant ces nouvelles applications et ces nouveaux appareils mobiles,
ces joujoux tout neufs,
à quel point sommes-nous prêts à adopter ce confort
aux dépens de notre intimité et notre sécurité ?
La prochaine fois que vous installez un programme,
vérifiez les réglages et demandez-vous,
« Est-ce que je souhaite partager ce type d'information ?
Est-ce que quelqu'un pourrait en abuser ? »
Il faut aussi accorder une attention particulière
au moyen de développer notre futur bassin de talents.
Vous savez, la technologie évolue à vitesse grand V,
250 000 logiciels malveillants
vont rapidement évoluer.
Il existe une tendance inquiétante :
alors que beaucoup d'étudiants qui sortent de l'école
sont bien plus au courant des technologies et savent les utiliser,
de moins en moins de personnes se renseignent
sur le réel fonctionnement de ces technologies.
Au Royaume-Uni, cette diminution représentait 60% par rapport à 2003,
et les statistiques mondiales sont similaires.
Nous devons aussi réfléchir aux problèmes légaux impliqués par ce secteur.
Les cybercriminels dont j'ai parlé,
malgré le vol de millions de dollars,
n'ont en fait jamais été arrêtés,
et ne le seront sûrement jamais.
La plupart des lois sont appliquées au niveau national,
malgré les séminaires sur le cybercrime, où Internet
n'a pas de frontières et est international, par définition.
Les pays sont en désaccord, ce qui rend ce secteur
extrêmement difficile d'un point de vue juridique.
Mais ma grande question est la suivante :
Vous voyez, en repartant,
vous allez lire l'actualité et entendre des histoires étonnantes.
Des articles à propos de logiciels malveillants qui font des choses
incroyables, terrifiantes, effrayantes.
Cependant, 99% de ce qui les fait marcher
est la négligence des gens à établir les éléments de sécurité essentiels.
Alors je vous demande d'aller en ligne,
de trouver les bonnes pratiques de base,
afin de savoir comment mettre à jour et protéger votre ordinateur.
Trouvez un mot de passe fiable.
Assurez-vous que vous utilisez différents mots de passe
pour chaque site et service en ligne que vous utilisez.
Trouvez ces informations. Appliquez-les.
Internet est une source fascinante.
pour les entreprises, l'expression politique,
l'art et l'apprentissage.
Aidez-moi et aidez la communauté de sécurité
à rendre la vie des cybercriminels
bien plus difficile.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)